you know the girls sleep on the floor of
our bedroom
and a few nights ago i smell a really
raunchy smell and i'm like who's farting
uh-oh right go to the obvious first
right all three of them are like sorry
it's me
so i go okay my family has gas big d you
know yeah make up in the morning wow
nobody's gas has dissipated something
smoke but it also smells like it's
burning it's one big sometimes stinky
slumber party at the shepherd bellhouse
that is not a joke in a new episode of
dak shepard's armchair expert podcast
the actor and his wife kristen bell
opened up about their sleeping
arrangement with their daughters
eight-year-old lincoln and
seven-year-old delta while discussing a
pretty gross mishap after noticing a
lingering unpleasant scent
that night i go to bed i'm like does
anybody else smell this like rotten
garbage like burning garbage smell now
delta the little one she is
smell sensitive so she goes you know
what i do smell it lincoln and dax can't
be bothered so delta and i are well
being gaslit well that's when kristen
says she played detective and hunted
down the source of the stench
i lean down and smell the mattress dax's
corner his feet corner of the mattress
and i
almost hit the deck i almost passed out
it was so strong yeah so turns out the
paris uhler mattress pad that needs to
be filled with water had in fact
accidentally been filled with dax's old
protein shake moral of the story don't
put a protein shake in your owler but
this isn't the first time the couple has
shared some unconventional details about
their home life with their kids over the
summer when ashton kutcher and mila
kunis were on the podcast they opened up
about waiting to bathe their kids until
they were visibly dirty
if you can see the dirt on them clean
them yeah otherwise there's no point
when i had children i also didn't wash
them every day like i wasn't the parent
that bathed my newborns ever
and dax and kristen defended their pals
during an appearance on the view sharing
that their own kids have a similar
bathing routine
sometimes five six days goes on i mean
they don't smell well that's right they
do
i'm a big fan of waiting for the steak
once you catch a whiff that's
that's biology's way of letting you know
you need to clean it up well all that
sparked what i refer to as the big
online bathing debate with stars like
cardi b dwayne the rock johnson and jake
gyllenhaal weighing in
were you surprised by the reaction how
many people weighed in i was in a
different country when this when this
storm hit it's great listen if it gets
people's mind off of reality who cares
and when eti chatted with kristen she
reminded everyone don't take it so
seriously it was funny because the whole
thing came out of a joke that my husband
made with ashton and mila on his podcast
and then it turned into this big thing
and then we were being asked in
interviews and we were like wait wasn't
this like just a joke you did on the
podca and everybody i think people need
maybe a little bit of a lesson about
what's a joke and what's not because now
people are adding it like it's an actual
supreme court case
[Music]
you